good morning
so
hey kevin good morning
speaker shirtless that uh that beard is
looking pretty epic uh it really is
i probably should trim it uh but uh
it's taking over my life now
with great beard comes great
responsibility uh i know
that's correct heavy is the head that
wears a beard
all right shakespeare said oh shoot us
that
morning steve good morning how you doing
kim
good how are you good thanks okay
look uh look like you're feeling much
better than the last time we saw you
yes i'm upright
[Laughter]
right i'm doing much better
so
you
hey paul um jason osmore jason osborne's
going to be joining as an attendee if
you can find him
um and bump him up to panelists
representative rice is representative
steve smith on site
i have not seen him
paul just so you know uh renny and lucy
and
david cody i think is on rules with us
um they're all on a leadership meeting
but they should be here
within a minute or two we're all here
it's it's lucy and tim and renny and
we're all here
oh okay the gang's oh you snap right in
there
hello steve hey ray how are you
you're on your cell phone aren't you
steve no i'm on my
ipad oh okay
why you're not using gallery view i'm
assuming
if you could see everybody oh
oh yeah well i can only see four people
including myself
but it's a great three others that i'm
seeing so
loving the beard steve oh thank you
i think anything that covers this face
up is a positive thing so it's
it's good for humanity you look jolly
he's hoping for compliments
mr chairman do you want me to uh to call
representative steve smith to see if
he's
logging in
uh we already have
we're just waiting another minute or two
to see if he responds
c
so
you
uh paul steve steve just come in he's uh
he's sitting right behind me here
you can possible
oh you can see him okay
all right so let's uh let's get is
everybody ready we can get going
if you could just give me one second mr
speaker
okay sir we are ready to roll
all right yes
representative smith apologizes accident
newport he said
as chair of the house rules committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor a result of
copen 19
pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
and house rule 67 this public body is
authorized to meet electronically
please note there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporary to this meeting which was
authorized pursuant
to the governor's emergency order
however in accordance emergency order
i'm confirming that we
are providing public access to the
meeting by telephone with additional
access possibilities by physical
video or other electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporarily during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporarily listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting through dialing the following
phone number
312-626-6799
webinar id 929-5516-0031
or https
dot slash www dot
zoom dot u s slash j
slash nine six two eight
three seven nine 7276
providing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting we
previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically this
information is printed in the house
calendar
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there is problems with access anybody
has a problem please call
603 271-3600
or email at hcs
at legislative at state dot new
hampshire
dot u s journey in the meeting if the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is enemy to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
it's all yours paul
chairman packard here uh
i'm in the uh office at the state house
and steve smith jason osborne
and deborah childs are in the office
vice chairman osborne uh here
in the speaker's office with the
aforementioned people
[Music]
representative rice i'm here at the
state house
in my office um and jennifer is
across the room
representative steven smith i'm here in
the speaker's office with the speaker
majority leader in deborah charles
representative sanborn here in my living
room in bedford
represent cushing i'm here in my home in
hampton
uh my wife is in the house but not in
the room
representative shirtless i'm at my home
in penacook
and i am alone representative weber
i'm at the house in concord i have a
friend sharing the house
not in the room with me at the moment
but might walk through
representative smith timothy smith
present
home office in manchester by myself
you have a full capacity attendance mr
chairman thank you mr clerk uh
well the first order of business is
approving the minutes of december 16
2020. if somebody would like to make a
motion i'm assuming everybody read them
and incorrect somebody like to make a
motion
to accept the minutes representative
smith moves to accept them in
steve smith is there a second second
representative
second in any discussion on the uh
motion to approve the minutes
if not then the clerk will call the roll
yes chairman osborne
yes representative rice yes
representative steven smith yes
representative sanborn
yes representative cushing yes
representative shirtless yes represent
weber
yes sorry about that i got a phone call
at the same time as i was trying to
unmute you
no worries representative timothy smith
yes
the motion to adopt the minutes passes
nine to zero mr chairman
okay the next order of business is uh
late drafting
an introduction of the budget bills one
two
and twenty five would uh can you have a
motion
i will make a motion representative
osborne makes a motion to
introduce and is there a second
second representative right second
discussion
okay if there's no discussion uh we'll
clerk will call a roll chairman packard
yes vice chairman osborne
yes representative rice yes
representing steven smith yes
representative sanborn
yes can you hear me representative
cushing
yes representative shirtless
yes representative yes
representative timothy smith yes
the motion for late drafting
introduction of house bills 1 2 and 25
is approved by a vote of 9-0 mr chairman
thank you
uh the next order of business is we have
a request by representative
splain for late drafting and
introduction of a bill
uh representative splain are you
with us um mr chairman i am looking in
our
uh list right now of callers
excuse me of of uh attendees i see that
there is
one caller um but i don't know
if that is representative spelling or
not
i do see that there are no members
attending
um with the the moniker of
representative spelaine
um if the if the caller
is representative spelaine
please press star six that should raise
your hand
and i will be able to promote you if
that is not
uh please don't
but i am not seeing
and that's the aforesaid person is not
raising their hand mr chairman uh i did
just send representative spelaine an
email a short time ago
uh reminding him of the meeting with the
link to attend
i have not heard back
okay uh we'll move on is there any other
business to come before the
rules committee this morning
representative weber has her hand raised
mr chairman
jenny webber thank you mr chairman i
i just had a quick question um in the
event that we want to
bring in a rules amendment which is
allowable
tomorrow under a majority vote
because of our emergency covert rule 67.
um i am right in thinking i just get the
text of that to the clerk for
presentation to the body tomorrow is
that correct
uh i'll let this sheriff i can
representative weber if i need that
today um because i understand i
understand you need it today i'm just
trying to save everybody time i don't
need to present that to this body i
simply would present it
to the clerk for presentation tomorrow
to the main body is that correct
that is correct okay thank you um
appreciate the clarification is there
any other business to come before the
rules committee
well this is a lot better than the last
one for four and a half hours
uh if there's no other business
i'll accept a motion to adjourn so moved
all right back in cushing and
representative shirtless
uh clerk will call the roll
representative packard yes
representative osborne
yes representative rice yes
representative stephen smith yes
representative sanborn
yes representative cushing yes
representative shirtless yes
representative weber yes representative
timothy smith
yes the motion to adjourn passes
mr chair nine to zero okay um
have a great day everybody see you all
tomorrow
take care thank you everyone for coming
in and we'll see everybody tomorrow